can you talk about the 1930s can you
describe what happened in holdem or the
soviet terror famine in ukraine and then
32 and 33 yes that killed millions of
ukrainians right it's a long story you
know but let me try to
be as succinct as i can be
i mean the hello de moore the the terror
famine of uh 3233
comes out of in part
and all union famine
that re that is the result
of collectivization you know
collectivization was a catastrophe
uh you know the more or less of the
so-called culocks the more or less
richer farmers i mean they weren't
really rich right
anybody with a tin roof and a cow was
considered a kulak you know and other
people who had nothing were also
considered kulaks if they opposed
collectivization so these kulaks were
talking millions of them right and
ukraine
it's worth recalling and i'm sure you
know this was a you know heavily
agricultural area and ukrainian peasants
um you know were on in the countryside
and resisted
collectivization more than even russian
peasants that resisted uh
collectivization
um suffered during this collectivization
program and they you know burned
sometimes their own houses they killed
their own animals
they were shot you know sometimes on the
spot
tens of thousands and others were sent
into exile
so there was a conflagration in the
countryside
and the result of that conflagration in
ukraine was terrible famine
and again there was famine all over the
soviet union but it was especially bad
uh in uh ukraine in part because
ukrainian peasants resisted
now in 32 33 a couple of things happen
i mean i've argued this in in my writing
and and and um you know i've also worked
on this i continue to work on it by the
way with
with a museum in in kiev that's going to
be about the holodemour they're they're
building the museum now and it's going
to be a very impressive uh set of
exhibits
and talk with historians all the time
about it so so what happens in 3233 are
a couple of things first of all
the
stalin
develops
and even stronger i say even stronger
because they already had an antipathy
for the ukrainians
and even stronger antipathy for the
ukrainians in general
first of all they resist
collectivization
second of all he's not getting all the
grain he wants out of them
and which he needs and so he sends in
then uh people to expropriate the grain
and take the grain away from the
peasants
these teams of people you know some
policemen some urban
thugs some party people
some poor peasants you know take part
two
go into the villages
and forcibly seize grain and um
and animals from the ukrainian peasantry
they're seizing it all over i mean let's
remember again this is all over the
soviet union in 32 especially
then
you know in december of 1932
january of 33 february of 33
stalin has convinced the ukrainian
peasantry um
needs to be shown who's boss
that they're not turning over their
grain
that they're resisting the expropriators
that they're hiding the grain which they
do sometimes right
that they're basically
not
loyal to the soviet union that they're
acting like traitors that they're ready
and he says this you know to i think
it's kaganovich he says it too you know
they're ready to kind of pull out of the
soviet union and join poland i mean he
thinks poland is you know out to get to
you out to get ukraine
and so he's going to then essentially
break the back of these peasantry and
the way he breaks their back
uh is by going through another
expropriation program which is not done
in the rest of the soviet union so he's
taking away everything they have
everything they have
their new laws introduced where they
will actually punish people including
kids
with death
if they steal any grain you know if they
take anything from the
you know from the fields
so you know you can shoot anybody
you know who is looking for food
and then he introduces measures in
ukraine which are not introduced into
the rest of the soviet union for example
the ukrainian peasantry are not allowed
to leave their villages anymore
they can't go the city to try to find
some things i mean we've got pictures of
you know ukrainian peasants dying on the
sidewalks and kharkiv and then kiev and
and places like that who've managed to
get out of the village and get to the
cities but now they can't leave
they can't leave ukraine to go to bella
russia
or belarus today or to russia you know
to get any food
there's no
he won't allow any relief to ukraine
number of people offer relief including
the polls but also the vatican offers
relief
he won't allow any relief to uk he won't
admit that there's a famine in ukraine
and instead what happens
is that ukraine turns into the ukrainian
countryside turns into what
my now uh
past colleague who died several years
ago robert conquest called
a vast belson
and by that you know the images of
bodies just lying everywhere
you know people dead
and uh
and dying
you know of hunger which is
by the way i mean
as you know i've spent a lot of time
studying genocide i don't think there's
anything worse than dying of hunger from
what i have read i mean you see terrible
ways that people die right
but dying of hunger is just such a
horrible horrible thing and so for
example
we know there were many cases of
cannibalism in the countryside because
there wasn't anything to eat people were
eating their own kids
right and stalin knew about this and
again
you know we started with this question a
little bit earlier he doesn't he there's
not a sign
of remorse not a sign of pity
right not a sign
of any kind of human emotion
that
normal people would have what about the
opposite of uh
joy
for teaching them a lesson i i don't
think there's joy i'm not sure stalin
really understood
emotion
no i i i i think he felt
it was necessary to get those sobs
right that they deserved it
he says that several times this is their
own fault
right this is their own fault
and as their own fault you know they get
what they deserve
basically how much was the calculation
how much was it reason versus emotion
in in terms of
you said he was competent
was there a long-term strategy or was
this strategy based on emotion and anger
and no i well i think actually the
the right answer is a little of both
i mean usually the right editor in
history is something like literally
right now you can't you can't
it wasn't just i mean first of all you
know the the soviets
had it in for ukraine and ukrainian
nationalism which they really didn't
like
and by the way russians still don't like
it right um
so they had it in for ukrainian
nationalism they feared ukrainian
nationalism
as i said you know stalin stalin writes
you know we'll you will lose ukraine you
know if these guys win
you know so there's a kind of long-term
determination
as i said you know to kind of break the
back
of ukrainian national
uh identity and ukrainian nationalism
as any kind of separatist force
whatsoever
and so there's that
rational calculation at the same time i
think stalin is annoyed
and um peeved
and
angry on one level with the ukrainians
for resisting collectivization
and for being difficult and for not you
know not conforming
uh you know to the way uh he thinks
uh peasants should act in this situation
so you have both things he's also very
angry at the ukrainian party
and eventually purges it for not being
able to control ukraine and not be able
to control the situation you know
ukraine is in theory the bread basket
right of europe well where how come the
bread basket isn't turning over to me
all this grain so i can sell it abroad
and
and you know build new factories and
support the workers in the cities
so there's a kind of annoyance you know
when things fail
and this is absolutely typical of stalin
when things fail he blames it on other
people and usually groups of people
right not individuals but groups
again so
a little bit of both i think is the
right answer
you